être un bon musulman en prenant du bon
temps et nous avons aussi une boutique
de services dont nous sommes très très
fiers
le kit mains-libres islamique avec un
niqab avec un téléphone intégré des
kinés de ma façon avec un bluetooth sans
oublier les applications halal pour
smartphones tu savais comme magasin
halal vendent pas de porc enfin qu'on
trouve dans le commerce en france tu
dois vendre du jambon et des lardons
moi je comprends pas j'ai toujours vendu
des jambes on garde toujours ça me
dérange pas papa arrête si tu étais pas
rapide direct et facho
on peut poser n'importe quelle question
je sais pas moi se gratter de
postérieurs pendant le ramadan halal ou
pas halal
et toi tu fais quoi alors dans la vie et
ben moi je suis drh
en fait tu peux leur dire c'est la
vérité
drh allaient est une [ __ ] très doué et
très sérieux dans son travail
j'espère que vous les accepterai pas ce
que je voulais comme les
voilà voilà
quand tu disputes tu veux dire escorte
but sur le trottoir quoi sur le trottoir
le sait c'est original c'est intéressant
et tu travailles sur sur quel trottoir
parce que je pense que c'est important
nous la localisation de 3 juin ne fais
pas tu es ma grand mère oui mais c'est
thérapeutique c'est pour mon cancer est
un cancer l'un mais je te paierai ya pas
de problème des retards maquette à
mettre les coudes tout nous sommes tous
les dieux parce qu'ils sont tous ont
subi mais dieu n'existe pas
tu le sais maman on t'a pas demander ton
avis on est tout seul dans la vie ça il
faut retenir un et personne ne te fera
de cadeau tu peux me passer un peu
d'argent ça m'étonnait aussi qu'ils
viennent nous voir sans raison
tu me fait beaucoup de peine après tous
les efforts que j'ai fait pour changer
sur la tête des assedic ou non je
passerai du liquide